you say you're looking for a last minute
gift yeah you did here's a suggestion or
two Amazon books editorial director
Sarah Gelman is back with us she's got
some books that she says makes great
presents for just about anybody on your
list Sarah good morning may I just say
you look very festive I like very much I
like it I wear this boss every day I'm
always going to shake shack later I
guess oh my God so first up it is a
holiday season you said you've got the
perfect book for people who love to host
parties yes the book is boards and it's
over there yes it's America's Test
Kitchen and it's styled by L Simone
Scott she is a food stylist she's also a
judge on the new competition show ATK
the Next Generation and if you love food
porn if you love beautiful photos of
food which I do this is great for you
but it's actually a legitimate book on
how to style these beautiful boards that
you're seeing all over social media and
what I love about this book is she takes
sort of the more you know classic
charcuterie board and then things that
are really unexpected like a steak-free
sport and throughout the book she shows
you how to style the boards how to make
them actually look really cool we'll
give you a step by step yes and like how
to swoosh your hummus and also how to
keep the board looking fresh all party
long nice because people love it when
they see it on IG and they're like how
do they do that exactly this is a book
for that exactly okay it's actually how
to make them so they look beautiful so
next up uh a cheeky book uh about pop
culture yes so this book is called butts
by Heather Radke yes yes that's a back
story but's a backstory I mean look at
the jacket I think that's good that is
beautiful oh no this is very
eye-catching obviously should we pause
do we have a couple more I know I know I
know don't I like this because I cannot
lie you got anything else so many
there's so many but you know what this
book it sounds silly but actually this
is a very smart and thought-provoking
book that is never boring about the
history of the female behind Okay and
only the female why why why that
limitation because it's more appreciated
because it's pretty yes
can you read the book or what okay all
right it is it's really it looks at the
the butt as a complex symbol of things
like shame and sexuality also used to
reinforce racial hierarchies and she
looks at all of this while also doing
things like quoting Simone de Beauvoir
Andrew Paul all in the same paragraph oh
wow uh okay neither one of those people
me neither but let's move on to The
Puzzler oh did you say RuPaul RuPaul Oh
I thought you said yeah you said RuPaul
I didn't think you said RuPaul's going
to be on tomorrow by the way so yeah
well yeah
okay uh okay The Puzzler yes AJ Jacobs
what's that about so Google revealed
last week that their most searched word
of the year was Wordle and this is for
people that love word games including
wordall I think but might have been the
most the first word but okay it will be
now for sure so if you love puzzles this
is definitely the book for you the
author makes this argument in the
introduction that by the end of the book
he's going to convince you that puzzles
can save the world and he looks at
everything from the history of the
Rubik's Cube to why British and American
crossword puzzles are different he's
very funny and celebrity met because I
really want to get to the celebrity
Memoir of the year and a kids book but
celebrity Memoir of the Year first yes
it's the book by Matthew Perry friends
lovers and the big terrible thing yes I
will say it might seem that gifting a
celebrity addiction Memoir for the
holidays doesn't say happy holidays but
this book is really so much more than a
celebrity tell-all it is definitely
entertaining if you love friends if you
love celebrity gossip it delivers on
that but it's a really intimate look at
addiction and mental Health struggles
and really the reality that money can't
buy happiness and also that problems
aren't always tied up in a pretty bow at
the end of it I saw the special Diane
Sawyer did with them very very revealing
kids book you recommend kids can cook
anything also America's Test Kitchen yes
so kids love cooking shows and they're
all these Junior versions of our
favorite shows like Top Chef kids and
this clutch yeah yeah so this actually
it teaches kids kind of basic techniques
but also how to build their culinary
repertoire it has recipes that range
from beginner intermediate and advanced
and tons of pictures throughout thank
you Sarah you've also got very first
encyclopedia I want that one thank you
always good to have you in this one well
I knew he was going to do something
we'll be right back we'll be right back